this morning we're taking a closer look
at one country's vaccine success story
to find out what the us can learn from
this israel aims to vaccinate its entire
adult population by the end of next
month becoming the first country to do
so that's impressive more than 40
percent of its population
has already received at least one shot
call that hashtag goals elizabeth palmer
has the story
those who could dance and those who
couldn't join from the sidelines as the
levgenin
care home threw a vaccination party near
tel aviv
oh it's so great thank goodness we get
the second vaccine today
we are celebrating we are going to be
free
just four months ago israel's coveted
outbreak
was one of the worst in the world under
strict lockdown people stayed home and
police set up
roadblocks to stop all but essential
travel
then in january israel's government
struck a deal with pfizer bioentech
enough vaccine for every adult within
three months
in exchange for valuable data on how
well it actually worked
you are in effect a living lab
for your own health officials but also
for pfizer
i think yeah we are a living lab but i
think to the world
not so much to pfizer i think it's
really something that the world can
learn from
and the world is learning that just as
science predicted
it's working in a study of more than a
million people
half were vaccinated and they were 94
percent
less likely to get coveted even the very
elderly
and real world evidence now shows that
the second shot
boosts immunity from solid to
spectacular
now even teens are getting vaccinated
prime minister netanyahu made his into a
photo op
he's facing re-election this spring and
hoping the successful vaccination
program
will offset anger on other issues
including corruption charges
netanyahu is also taking some flack for
paying pfizer
a third more per dose than the u.s paid
but here's the payoff just days ago
lockdown was eased
and israelis are out and about enjoying
their freedom again
i'm free i can go anywhere i don't have
to stay home i can see my
friends my family i think we can say
goodbye
to kovit19 eventually
now israel has taken some criticism for
not vaccinating millions of palestinians
who live on land it occupies
the palestinians are at last starting to
get a little bit of vaccine from various
sources including israel but the fact
is very few of them have had a chance to
get a shot
tony that's an important note there at
least bomber for us in london
reporting on israel